那哪怕今天你是最頂尖的短線交易者
你交易了十幾年之後
你也會知道這個遊戲是很難贏的
就是短線交易的市場是非常困難的
所以第一你不會製造一個
短線交易很容易
上槓桿交易很容易
很快在很短時間賺到一個錢
這樣的一個氛圍
我覺得我常鼓勵大家去創業
原因是什麼就是因為
你今天你要真的扭轉階級
你要真的可以跳脫這個框架
創業基本上是
我覺得是為二的機會
真正進步是打魔獸世界
就是逼著自己要講英文
工會人都講英文嗎
所以就
就是逼著自己要講
然後在那個打魔獸世界那幾年
就英文就進步很快
所以今天當你想要變好的時候
你要知道的事情是
不要聽這些
以你最親近的人的意見
你要去聽一些
以你目標最接近的人的意見
哇 這個是友誼一期的那個金句
我印象特別深刻
你任何時候是
其實有這個想法是非常蠻危險的
在這個圈子做內容的人
就是不管是KOL或是YouTuber
就是他們都年紀比較輕
比較容易傳達一個
要快 要賺得多這樣的概念
那這個概念是非常非常危險的
在市場當中你要做的事情是慢
是要穩
絕對不是快 跟賺得多
就是快跟賺得多是基本上
百分之百會賠錢的事情
你基本上沒有看過一個
我們就說35、40歲以上的人
或者是一個比較有名的企業家或者交易者
然後在公開場合告訴大家說你要去玩短線
基本上你沒有看過這樣
原因是因為你今天到了35歲 40歲以上的時候
那哪怕今天你是最頂尖的短線交易者
你交易了十幾年之後你也會知道這個遊戲是很難贏的就是短線交易的市場是非常困難的所以第一你不會製造一個短線交易很容易 上槓桿交易很容易
很快在很短時間賺到一個錢這樣的一個氛圍
你不會去賽單說你這一個交易賺了多少幾百個percent
因為你會知道有其他交易是賠錢的
就沒有一個交易者是勝率百分之一百
甚至沒有一個交易者是勝率百分之七十的
大部分最頂尖的交易者他們勝率可能是55%
可能是57%
賭場的很多遊戲
他們的勝率其實就是個53-54%
所以就變成說今天我跟妳甩甩子
或是我跟妳玩個比大小好了
假如說今天我勝率是53%
然後妳的勝率有47%
妳今天妳假如說妳想要玩個三次
妳有可能三次都贏
就哪怕妳的勝率只有47%
妳也有可能三次都贏
但是因為這三次都贏妳就會覺得妳好像有機會
但是如果妳用理智去看這件事情的話
假如說今天妳的equity只有47%的話
你長期玩這個遊戲就是100%是賠錢的
怎麼講 我常常鼓勵大家去創業
原因是什麼 就是因為今天你要真的扭轉階級
你要真的可以跳脫這個框架 創業基本上是
我覺得是為二的機會 肯定是超過投資的啦
那投資的話是屬於比較被動的
然後你的天花板是有限的 創業的天花板是無限的
所以任何一個想創業的人我覺得都值得被鼓勵
但是我個人覺得創業成功的機率跟短線交易其實沒有差多少
就是可能也是不到1%
一個經濟週期賺錢的公司非常非常多
但是今天你要經歷多個金融週期
然後持續能賺錢的公司真的是很少
就是在5年之後一個公司開5年
開10年可以持續經營的情況下
這個百分比是非常非常少的
我覺得學語言最好的方式就是丟到一個就是只要逼著你必須講這個語言的地方你就必須要學就像我其實剛來美國的時候頭大概三年的時間吧
英文沒有什麼進步
原因就是因為身邊都是一些台灣人
香港人還有大陸人嘛
那大家都講中文
真正進步是打魔獸世界
就是逼著自己要講英文
工會人都講英文嘛
所以就是逼著自己要講
然後在那個打魔獸世界那幾年
那幾年英文就進步很快
所以我覺得學一個語言呢
就是你一定要去到一個
沒有人跟你講中文的地方
就是逼著你要講當地的語言
你就會學得非常非常快
那這也是學語言最快的方式
今天我相信一個好的投資者
今天一個有責任的投資者
不會在這個自己不了解項目的時候
就把大筆身家壓在上面
所以第一個循環當中
就我們就說第一個牛市
對大部分的投資者來講
比較正常的情況下
我講不是那些賭徒
我想是一些比較正常的 有邏輯的投資者
第一個循環 你能放在市場的錢是比較有限的
因為你會不知道說這個東西適不適合你
當你信念沒有這麼深的時候
你不可能把100%的資產都放在上面
因為你不知道會發生什麼事情
那牛市到頂了
再進入到熊市的過程
你的資產可能會迎來一個8-90%
甚至是如果是愛達比的話是95-97%的虧損
那在這樣的一個虧損下
你如果可以持續的待在市場裡面
你還持續的覺得說這個板塊是很有希望的
就是持續在關注這些東西的話
你就很有機會會賺到真正的錢
所以今天當你想要變好的時候
你要知道的事情是
不要聽這些離你最親近的人的意見
你要去聽一些離你目標最接近的人的意見哇這個是友誼一期的那個金句耶我象特别深刻对对就真的今天你想要讲到一个你想要看一下很好很好吃的蛋糕店
那你今天你不会听一些
你身边最好的朋友
你不会听你身边亲朋好友
家人的意见
你要去听的是
整个城市里面最屌的蛋糕店
他的老板是怎么做到这件事情
你要去听他的意见
对吧
所以所以你今天
你想做什么事情的时候
你就要听离你目标
最近的人的意见
而不是听你最亲近的人的意见
它就是一个你慢慢把货币
变成资产的一个过程
就是这么简单
股市市场就是这么简单
它就是一个把紫钞体系
美金台币人民币欧元
慢慢转换成资产的一个过程
这个资产的选择
可以是股票
可以是S&P大盘
可以是房地产
可以是加密货币
那今天任何时候你要贩售资产
去讨顶或者讨一个循环顶的时候
你只要问你自己的问题
就是今天有某一刻紙鈔是不再貶值了嗎
同來都沒有對吧
所以紙鈔就是一個持續貶值的東西
那紙鈔貶值代表就是資產會持續的膨脹
就是以數字來講資產會持續的膨脹
那如果在你知道這樣的一個邏輯的情況下
你為什麼要去猜說現在可能是資產的頂部
然後你要把一個你確定長期會
隨著時間增加價值的資產
換成一個你確定長期會貶值的紙鈔
就是我覺得這個是一個很內套的事情
因為你當你今天你判斷錯的時候
你會不停的安排自己
你會想說學為什麼要不做
然後我賣OSHO
我在10萬買掉了
他需要20萬30萬
就是你會一直自己
我覺得在投資場當中
我自己我不喜歡浪費時間在懷疑自己的決定到底對不對